FEMALE SPEAKER: All right.
Hi, everyone.
So a little bit about Maria.
She is a brand strategist,
author and speaker, who
believes cash flow and
creativity are
not mutually exclusive.
As brand chief strategist and
creator of Red Slice, she
advises start-ups, solopreneurs,
and small- to
mid-sized growth companies
on how to craft
irresistible brands.
Maria is the author of two
books, "Branding Basics for
Small Business," and, what
we're going to look into
today, her humorous and
heartfelt memoir "Rebooting My
Brain." So Maria's been also
featured on MSNBC, ABC News,
NPR, "Entrepreneur,"
and the "LA Times."
We often don't get to hear a lot
about severe brain trauma
patients, because, sadly, they
don't always have the means or
cognitive ability to communicate
their experience.
Maria has had an amazing
recovery from a ruptured brain
aneurysm just over
four years ago.
She now uses her voice to
educate and inspire others
about both the unseen effects
of brain injury, as well as
how to bounce back after
any crisis yanks
you out of your life.
So please, let me welcome, and
join me to welcome Maria Ross.
Thank you.
MARIA ROSS: Thanks for
having me today.
I really appreciate it.
So yeah, as Rachel said,
my name is Maria Ross.
And I want to talk to
you a little bit.
My mission is two-fold in
talking to you today.
Number one is to educate you a
little bit about brain injury
and brain aneurysms,
in particular.
As we all know from all the
quarterbacks that got
concussions this past weekend
in the NFL, brain injury is
finally getting in
the spotlight.
And so more people need to
understand some of the unseen
effects that go along with it,
because too often, people try
to diagnose it as, oh,
they look fine.
And so I'm really on a mission
to educate people about what
brain injury patients, no matter
how they got their
brain injury-- whether it's
concussion, or, like me, an
aneurysm, or a stroke or some
other traumatic event--
many of the effects
are the same.
So I'm on a mission to educate
as well as inspire people,
because my story, where I was
in my life, is probably very
similar to where you guys are.
And when life yanks you out of
it because of a crisis, it can
really can make you
lose your balance.
And so it's all about how
do you get back into the
slipstream of your life and
rebuild, hopefully, a little
bit wiser and a little bit
changed by the experience.
So let me paint a picture for
you of what was going on when
this whole aneurysm hit my
life and the life of my
husband, Paul.
In 2007, we had been living in
the San Francisco Bay Area--
and I had been here for
almost eight years--
both living similar lives to
what you guys are living.
We were both marketing
professionals, marketing
executives in technology,
working down in the valley,
living up in San Francisco.
So commuting, really fast-paced
lifestyle, really
doing a lot and trying
to fit a lot in.
My husband got a job offer
from Microsoft.
So we ended up moving to Seattle
because of that.
And you can imagine that
that was a huge change.
Not only did we move to
a new city, but we
had to make new friends.
We bought our first house.
We adopted our first dog.
And as if that wasn't enough
change and stress, after my
company that I was working for
in the valley had some
layoffs, I decided to hang out
my own shingle and start my
brand consultancy, which I'd
wanted to for a long time.
So I was getting into the swing
of owning a new business
and all the legal requirements
and the accounting
requirements and networking and
trying to build up that
base of clients.
So it was a really crazy and
stressful time for us.
And we were going at, probably,
about 300 miles an
hour, as I'm sure many of
our lives feel like in
this day and age.
In addition to all of
that-- as if, again,
that all wasn't enough--
I'm also an actress
in my spare time.
So I was investigating the
Seattle theater scene as well,
thinking I'm not sure how I was
going to have time to do
another play on top
of all of this.
So it was a pretty crazy time.
And after an initial episode--
which maybe we can talk about
in the Q&A if you want--
I started having some pretty
debilitating migraines on a
regular basis, to the point
that I was vomiting.
I couldn't go into work.
And there was one particular
episode that
stopped me in my tracks.
And when I went to the doctor,
he thought it was just all the
stress and change that was
going on in our lives.
And my blood pressure
was through the roof
when he took it.
But there's high blood pressure
in my family, so we
really weren't surprised that
all the stress and change had
caused the high blood
pressure.
So fast forward about a month
and a half of the occasional
dealing with these headaches,
monitoring my blood pressure.
He said to monitor it for a
month and, if it wasn't going
down, to come back in.
I was about to get ready to make
that call to go back in
to see him.
But on August 4, 2008, I
collapsed, unconscious, on my
bathroom floor.
And luckily, my husband decided
to leave work early
that day and come home and
work from home, because I
wasn't feeling well.
So had he not been
there, I probably
wouldn't be here today.
But he immediately called 911.
And we also were very fortunate
enough to live about
five miles from the region's
top trauma center that
attracts some of the top
neurosurgeons in the country.
So that was another stroke of
luck or destiny that was on my
side that day.
And when they rushed me to
the ER, unconscious and
unresponsive, they did an
emergency scan and found that
an aneurysm had ruptured, and
it was causing a hemorrhage.
So before we go any further, I
just want to clarify a few
definitions.
How many of you know what
an aneurysm is?
Anyone?
Yeah.
I didn't know what
it was either.
So I always thought an aneurysm
was an event, like a
heart attack, like someone
has an aneurysm.
But an aneurysm is
actually a thing.
It's a ballooning of a weak spot
in your artery wall or
your blood vessel.
And it can either get so big
that it causes problems.
Or, like in my case, it can
rupture, because of all the
pressure of your blood pumping
through the vessel as it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger,
until, like a balloon, it
actually pops.
So I wanted to read some
statistics to you about brain
aneurysm, because a lot
of people don't
know a lot about it.
An estimated 6 million people
in the US have an unruptured
aneurysm but don't know it.
That's about 1 in 50 people.
So you can actually have an
aneurysm and live your life
and be fine.
And it may never cause
you any problems.
In fact, I actually have
another aneurysm
that's really small.
But because of what happened to
me, it's being monitored by
the doctors.
The rate of rupture is
approximately 8 per 100,000
people, or 25,000 people.
And about 40% of all people
who have ruptured brain
aneurysm will die as a result.
Four out of seven people who
actually survive will have
disabilities.
And shockingly enough, the
most prevalence of brain
aneurysms is in people between
the ages of 35 and 60.
So I had my aneurysm burst
when I was 35.
And everyone thought,
oh, that's so young.
But it's actually right in the
beginning of that sweet spot.
And for some reason that science
hasn't quite figured
out yet, women suffer more than
men from brain aneurysms,
at a ratio of about
three to two.
And brain aneurysm ruptures
are 3% to
5% of all new strokes.
So it's pretty compelling,
when you look at the
statistics, that someone,
somewhere may be touched in
their lives, either themselves
or someone close to them, by a
ruptured brain aneurysm.
And I've heard so many stories
from emails, since I've gotten
the book, about all different
kinds of scenarios, where
people discovered their aneurysm
or had it rupture and
didn't know or had misdiagnosis
upon misdiagnosis
from doctors.
So a lot of the nonprofit groups
that are out there
really seek to not just educate
the public but educate
primary care physicians.
Because many of them
don't-- like mine--
know that those are the
common symptoms of
an unruptured aneurysm.
So back to the ER, they also
discovered that when I had
this ruptured aneurysm--
obviously, when it ruptures,
it causes a cerebral
hemorrhage.
And that's really where
the danger is.
In my case, the specific
hemorrhage that I had was
called a subarachnoid
hemorrhage.
And it doesn't have anything
to do with spiders.
But as one doctor explained to
me in a great way, he said,
it's really just not your
brain and your skull.
There's a bunch of layers that
protect your brain, sort of
like Saran Wrap, that you
don't really know the
technical terms for.
And between two of those layers
is a space called the
subarachnoid space.
And what makes that hemorrhage
really dangerous is that it's
not localized.
So once it gets into the
subarachnoid space, it
actually surrounds the
circumference of your brain
and causes pressure, which
is what is really
deadly in most cases.
The subarachnoid hemorrhage
is about 1% to
7% of all new strokes.
And the statistics around that
is about 50% of the people who
have those don't survive.
About 10% to 15% of them
never even make it to
the hospital in time.
And of those that survive, they
often have neurological
or cognitive impairments.
So it was pretty nasty.
And I'm very blessed
and very lucky.
And I've actually surprised many
of my neurosurgeons with
my recovery, because I really
beat the statistics with
what's happening to me.
But to get back to the story,
so I was in the hospital, in
summary, around six
weeks, total.
I was in the ICU for about three
or four weeks, between
ICU and the neurosurgery ward.
What they did was,
initially, they
have to stop the bleeding.
That's the imperative the day
that I was brought in.
And there's two ways to
stop an aneurysm.
One way is clipping, which is,
literally, you go in and you
surgically almost, like,
put a clothespin and
close off the aneurysm.
The other way, depending on
where it's located and how big
it is, is to do a coiling,
which is what
they did with me.
They did it an emergency coiling
procedure, which is
pretty crazy.
So they go through an artery
in your thigh.
And they put a catheter
that goes all the
way up to your brain.
And they thread platinum
wires, one by one, and
basically create a knitted ball
to block the flow of the
blood in the aneurysm.
So it's basically like I have
a plug that's stopping the
flow of the blood from
the aneurysm.
So that kind of blows my mind.
Pardon the pun.
So that's what they
did with me.
And then, as a result, I had a
couple of other setbacks while
I was in ICU and neurosurgery.
I had what's called
an angioplasty.
Because a common side effect
from brain trauma is, a few
days later, like clockwork, what
happens is your brain is
trying to protect itself
from the trauma.
So some of your blood vessels
snap shut without warning.
And that can cause stroke-like
symptoms.
So for me, it was a degradation
of my left side,
just about the third or fourth
day that I was in ICU.
And they realized I needed
an angioplasty.
And that's just, basically, when
they go in with a balloon
and pump up and prop up the
blood vessel again so that
it's not snapped shut anymore.
I also had an issue with an
increase of intracranial
fluid, or ICF, which, again, is
common with brain trauma.
What happens is our bodies
all produce ICF
on a regular basis.
And in a normal, healthy body,
it's absorbed back into the
bloodstream in a routine way.
But when you have a brain
trauma, sometimes the body
can't absorb the fluid as fast
as it's being produced.
And so it causes excess pressure
on your brain.
So they did several spinal taps
on me, but it's still
wasn't alleviating
the pressure.
So I had to get a shunt
implanted in my skull, which
is still there.
And that's just sort of like a
release valve, that when the
fluid built up too high, it
would release the fluid.
There's actually a tube that
goes down the back of my ear
and down my chest into
my abdominal area.
Now, it's probably not working
now, because this was over
four years ago.
But it's too invasive to go
back in and remove it.
So I just sort of have this
shunt in my head for the rest
of my life.
And then in addition, I did a
couple weeks of inpatient
therapy while I was in the
hospital, because I also
forgot to mention, I was blind
the entire time that I was in
the hospital.
I had what's called Terson's
syndrome, which is a side
effect of a subarachnoid
hemorrhage, because the hits
just keep on going.
And it basically caused another
hemorrhage in my
retinas that impaired
my vision.
So I had no short-term memory.
I was on ICU drugs and totally
confused and rambling and
making up stories and
conspiracy theories.
And then, on top of that,
I couldn't see.
So that was my experience
in the hospital.
I got released.
And then a week later, the eye
doctors did a surgery on one
of my eyes, to at least
clear the vision so
that I could rehab.
But they don't like to do that,
because they don't like
mucking in your eye if
they don't have to.
So they let the other eye heal
on its own, which took about 9
or 10 months for it to
completely clear out to the
point that I could
drive again.
And then, when I got home, I
continued therapies, physical,
occupational, and speech.
And speech was not because I
had speech problems, but
speech covers all the cognitive
issues that you
have-- so memory, organization,
comprehension,
vocabulary recall.
I was not speaking as fast as
I'm speaking right now.
I couldn't find the right words,
which still kind of
hits me every now and then,
on a daily basis.
But I went through different
therapies.
And then, after a few months,
I went to some group rehab
therapies, both cognitive
and psychotherapy.
Because there's a lot of effects
that come with brain
injury, again, whether it's
a stroke or traumatic or
whatever, things like
depression, things like
anxiety, things like aggression,
lack of filter.
Some people really lose
their social graces.
If you've ever met someone who's
had a stroke and has had
that particular impact, if it's
a frontal lobe injury, it
can impact your regulation
center.
So some people say inappropriate
things or do
inappropriate things or
things like that.
The other big one, that was a
huge surprise for me, was your
initiation gets impacted
chemically.
So in that part of your brain
where your executive skills
are stored, that also stores
your get-up-and-go, your
ability to initiate, your
ability to start something.
And so I struggled for a really
long time as to why
this was happening to me.
Because I couldn't figure out
why I wasn't back to the old
Maria, of doing 500 things and
making things happen and being
type A and being a
control freak.
And that was really
what was going on.
So those group therapies really
helped with that.
But it took about six or seven
months, which is actually
quite fast given what
had happened to me.
But I slowly started to get back
into work again and test
the waters.
The challenge with a brain
injury like mine is, because
there's nothing physical
that you see--
I mean, if you break your arm
or you break your foot, you
know when it's healed, right?
And you know there's
a problem.
But how do know you're not as
good at prioritization anymore
until you have to prioritize?
So I had to get back into work
just to test the boundaries of
what was happening to me.
And over the course of the
recovery, that full year, as I
was slowly getting back into
work and doing client work
again and making sure I wasn't
screwing up my accounting
books or anything like that,
and then even the last few
years, I deal with things
differently.
I've learned to adapt to, what
I call, the new me, because I
had to learn to adapt to
things being different.
And things that used to
come easy for me don't
come as easy for me.
So my brain has to
work harder.
That also means that fatigue
is a huge issue with brain
injury patients and can
sometimes last the whole rest
of their lives.
So I have to plan my weeks very
carefully and my days,
because if I try to do too much
in one day, it literally
exhausts me, because my brain's
working harder to do
things that used to be a little
bit more automatic than
they are now.
So I tell you all this because,
whether it's a brain
aneurysm or whether it's a
divorce or a death or a
medical diagnosis, we all have
some major crisis at some
point, unfortunately, that, like
I mentioned before, yanks
us out of our lives.
And I was fortunate enough, with
my recovery, that I was
able to see what happened
to me as a gift.
I know there's a lot of other
patients that I hear from that
are not as fortunate as I am.
But I did learn to re-frame my
life and reboot my brain,
which is why I call the book
"Rebooting My Brain." Because
I was forced to.
Because I had to learn how
to operate in a new way.
And I learned some valuable
lessons about what got me
through that crisis that can
apply to any crisis of you
trying to get back on
your feet again.
So I'm going to share those
with you and read a couple
passages that illustrate
those points.
There's three major ones that,
as I was writing the book, I
started to realize were
important to getting back into
your life again.
And the first one is really
all about patience.
I am a redhead, and
I'm also Italian.
I'm 100% Italian.
So patience is not something
that I'm
really well versed in.
And being a type-A personality,
I'd always
equated patience as a very
negative thing, that maybe
people didn't care enough if
they were too patient.
Or they were just being lazy
if they were trying to be
patient and wait things out.
And I was pretty much smacked
in the face that I had to
learn to be patient.
And I wasn't going to go back
to normal two weeks later,
which is what I was telling
my doctors as I'm in the
hospital, blind, with a shaved
head, with tubes in my head,
going yeah, I'm going to get
back to work in five weeks.
I mean, all over my charts,
they're like, she seems to not
understand the severity
of her injury.
So I really had to learn
that lesson.
And I'm going to read a quick
passage to you that
exemplifies that.
Because my husband and I had
this really great trip to
Spain planned, that happened
right when this aneurysm hit.
So, obviously, we didn't go, but
I couldn't let go of the
fact that we weren't
going to be going.
So I'm just adapting this
passage for you.
"During that crazy autumn in the
hospital, I faced my first
lesson with a teacher that
came along and smacked me
around quite often
during recovery--
patience.
Paul and I had spent early
2008 planning a trip to
northern Spain.
Our plan was to jet off to
Bilbao out for a romantic
five-day road trip, heading
south into the Rioja region to
spend the night at a charming
winery bodega, then cruising
east into the Pyrenees for
hiking in the mountains, and
finally up to San Sebastian,
along the northern coast, for
two days of seaside fun.
The trip was scheduled for
September 10, 2008, about five
weeks after all hell
broke loose.
I, however, was convinced we
were still going to get on
that plane and fly halfway
across the globe.
Shaved, blind, frail, weak,
underweight, fatigued,
cognitively damaged, I still
believed we were going to be
sunning ourselves in Spain,
munching on Manchego, and
sipping Rioja.
Mind you, Paul told me several
times that he'd canceled the
trip, but I kept forgetting.
I constantly said, don't forget
to ask the doctor if I
can fly with the shunt
in my head.
Paul would sigh and have to tell
me, again and again and
watch me get angry,
again and again.
But we have to go, I pleaded.
It'll help me heal, I cajoled.
We're really not going to
be doing much walking.
It'll be good for
me, I reasoned.
I wasn't even going to be
released from the hospital
until September 12, but I still
thought we were going.
People who don't know the real
me, the medical staff for
instance, thought this
was merely my
brain injury at play--
memory deficiencies,
aggression,
over-emotional outbursts.
And it partly was.
But I also have an insanely
stubborn streak born of my
Italian heritage and my status
as a feisty redhead.
Patience is just not
in my vocabulary.
I was forced to learn that life
is not on my timeline.
This brain injury was one glitch
I was not going to be
able to overcome with sheer
determination and grit.
This was serious business, and
I had serious healing to do.
For someone who is used to
simply making up her mind and
getting things done, how was I
going to learn that I could
not go from 0 to 100, or
hospital bed to Spanish beach,
in 60 seconds?
Now, once again, I was put in
my place, when I tried to
rally against something I could
not control, simply by
willing it to be so.
Most likely, this delusion that
I can control everything,
combined with my inability to
surrender to things outside of
that control, led to the damn
aneurysm in the first place.
I had to learn that this
was more serious
than I wanted to admit.
Several psychologists noted
in my chart that they were
concerned I didn't fully
appreciate the severity of my
injury and that I was
overestimating my current
abilities and recovery time.
Progress had to happen
in small steps,
not in giant leaps.
I was going to have to set some
goals, yet focus on the
immediate step in front of me in
order to make any progress.
There had already been enough
setbacks just while I was in
the hospital, and there would
be more when I left.
But patience, a virtue with
which I've always struggled,
finally had me by the throat.
And I was going to have to
listen if I wanted to pick up
my life again.
It dawned on me that this was
the beginning of re-framing
the way I lived my life if I
wanted to have a life to
live."
So the second lesson that really
helped me get back on
my feet was all about
acceptance.
And again, this is another word
that I'd equated very
negatively as compromise or
not getting what you want.
And I had to learn that
there was a new me.
I kept trying to get back to the
old me and do things the
way I used to do them before.
And I was actually my own worst
enemy, for a really long
time, during this crisis,
because I kept thinking the
game was the same.
And the game had changed, and I
had to accept that in order
to overcome it.
So I'm going to read a quick
passage to you about one of
the lessons in that.
When I was home, and I was
trying to start to get used to
working again, I literally
couldn't get up off the couch,
and I couldn't understand why.
I mean, I was still healing.
I was still blind in one eye.
It wasn't like I was
completely healthy.
But I couldn't understand, as I
was mentioning, this lack of
initiation.
I couldn't understand why I just
couldn't get myself down
to my desk and at least check
email for 10 minutes a day.
So we brought a speech therapist
back in to help put
me on a schedule and
get me ready to get
back to work again.
And she really opened my eyes
as to this fact that things
were different now.
And her name is Jane.
So I'm just reading a
quick passage about
my work with her.
"It was like the sun burst
into my cloudy day.
I don't know if it was her
education and experience with
what was happening to me or her
reassurance that what I
was going through was normal,
given my brain injury, but it
helped me get past trying
to make sense of it
all and just adapt.
Acceptance--
that lesson was key to
getting me through
the rest of my recovery.
Before this, I had seen
everything as
so black and white.
If I say I'm brain injured,
I won't ever
get back to my life.
So I'll minimize the injury
as much as possible
and just push through.
I had thought admitting to
change meant I was broken.
What I learned from Jane
was that there was
going to be a new me--
not better or worse, but new.
I could fight it all I wanted,
but the sooner I accepted this
new reality, the sooner I could
adapt and deal with it.
Acceptance doesn't
mean giving up.
It's seeing the reality in front
of you and making the
best out of the situation.
To me, getting well had meant
getting back to the old
baseline again.
Not true.
It was now a new
playing field.
Getting healthy meant that I
needed to honestly assess the
obstacles and then see how far I
could knock them over or how
I could zip around
them instead.
Jane let some light into that
darkness, so I could realize
it was not about the old me.
It was about the here and now
and making the new me work.
Working with her rebooted
my system and
my approach to recovery.
This turning point, of asking
for help, completely rewired
my thinking."
And one of the things that you
may have gotten with your book
is a card for a free
trial from a
website called Lumosity.
It's a brain games website
developed by a bunch of
neuroscientists.
It's actually based
in the Bay Area.
And Jane actually turned
me on to that website.
And playing those games, it
has been shown, they're
finding, to help improve brain
injury patients and stroke
patients as well.
So I played those games
for several weeks.
And actually, it helped me
get my vocabulary back.
It helped me get my cognitive
edge back.
And it helped me with recall,
as well as things like
visual-spatial recognition,
which I was
having problems with.
So it's a really
great website.
And you have a card there for a
one-month free trial if you
want to check it out.
So the third lesson, which is,
I think, a really important
one, no matter what challenge
we're facing,
is to find the humor.
So you might think,
OK, this is a
near-fatal brain aneurysm.
There's nothing really
funny about that.
But my family and friends, true
to form, found moments of
humor to lighten their stress
and lighten their
mood and just cope.
It's a human reaction, and
people shouldn't feel guilty
about making off-color jokes.
I mean, my husband and I,
between us, we joke a lot
about brain injury and
things like that.
And sometimes, we do it in front
of other people, and
they're kind of shocked.
But that's how we
deal with it.
So it's OK to let go and find
the humor in things.
I think it really helps people
deflate the pressure and be
able to problem solve and
think more clearly.
So there was actually a lot to
laugh about, even though I
don't remember the entire
month of August, 2008.
My friend, who's a writer, who
happened to be in town, in
Seattle, the weekend that this
happened and extended her
stay, she started a journal for
me, where she documented
everything that was
going on in ICU.
And a few other people chimed
in with entries.
But she noted all these humorous
moments, even though
they didn't know if these were
things that were going to last
me the rest of my life.
Because of the drugs and because
of the brain injury
and because of being in ICU, a
common side-effect is called
ICU psychosis.
And I don't know if any of have
actually had friends or
family in the ICU.
But often people will come up
with conspiracy theories.
They'll get paranoid.
They'll think they're late for
meetings they never had.
They think there's things
they need to be doing
that it's not true.
They just start making
things up.
And so some of these stories,
I was saying, were actually
pretty funny.
And she documented some of them,
hoping that one day we'd
be able to laugh about
it, which we do.
But my husband, in
particular--
obviously, you can guess, he
was under a lot of stress.
And he found his own way of
humorously dealing with this
situation, among other things.
So I'm going to read you
this quick passage.
"As the days passed, medical
staff did daily neurological
assessments, sometimes
multiple times a day.
They asked me a series of
questions to see where I was,
from a cognitive standpoint.
While I could have conversations
when I was alert
and awake, I still didn't
always have a
firm grasp on reality.
But I think my friends and
family enjoyed the barraged of
questioning more than I did,
especially my friend Tracy,
who wrote, 'they started a lot
of testing and assessment for
future therapy.
Lots more questions followed.
The first being, does
a cork float?
I wasn't sure on this either.
We just drink the wine.
We don't bother putting
the cork in water.'
Over the course of my hospital
stay, Paul, along with
everyone else, turned to humor
as a coping mechanism.
He invented his own battery
of memory tests.
That fall, two prominent men
made headlines, John Edwards
and Brett Favre.
John Edwards' scandal involved
a secret affair.
Brett Favre, the famous Green
Bay Packers quarterback, went
to play for the New York Jets.
As I'm a big football fan, this
bit of news mattered to
me, because I loved Brett Favre,
and I'm a Jets fan.
Each day, Paul asked me, do you
remember what I told you
about John Edwards?
Do you remember what I told
you about Brett Favre?
And each day I forgot.
You know that movie, "50 First
Dates" with Drew Barrymore and
Adam Sandler, where each day he
has to woo his girlfriend
all over again, because
she suffers from
no short-term memory?
Yeah, it was kind
of like that.
Shut up.
No way, I would exclaim in
shock, every single time.
Never gets old, he joked.
But Paul's amusement masked a
nagging worry that I might be
like this for the
rest of my life.
In the vast blackness of a month
entirely lost to memory,
I know there were glimpses of
the old Maria that offered
hope and comfort to everyone,
just as much as there were
some scary setbacks.
Even in my ramblings, I itched
to be busy, telling people the
location of things that I
thought I needed from home--
I didn't--
or asking what I needed
to be doing--
nothing.
My mind reeled off an ambitious
to-do list on
autopilot, even though
none existed.
Not all of it made sense, but
everyone took it as a good
sign that I wanted to
be kicking ass and
taking names again.
Especially Carey, who wrote,
'August 9, 2008.
We're trying to sort out a
good pillow-bed position
because of your neck pain.
So you're getting jostled
quite a bit.
During one of the jostles,
your gown slipped a bit.
And you said, very distinctively
to the nurse,
well, shit, and yanked
it back up.
Little victories, tiny friend,
little victories,'"
So I share those lessons with
you about patience,
acceptance, and humor, again,
because I'm hoping that you
don't have to have a brain
aneurysm to be able to find
opportunities in your everyday
adversities to re-frame the
conversation.
I was forced to because of
what had happened to me.
And like I said earlier, I'm
fortunate enough to see this
as a gift because of my
amazing recovery.
But a lot of these changes I'm
really glad that I've made, in
terms of slowing down and
appreciating the moment a
little bit more and trying to
control my stress level.
Because of that other aneurysm
that I have, that I mentioned,
I do have to keep my blood
pressure in check so that it
doesn't get any bigger.
And I'm not perfect.
I haven't reached some Zen
Buddhist state about my life.
And I still get caught
up in things.
I still work with crazy clients
and doing all sorts of
stuff like that.
But I try to stay a little bit
centered and a little bit
present, realizing that there
are worse things that could be
happening to me right now.
So I just want to leave you with
one last passage, which
is kind of about a lot of
thinking that I did because of
the changes that
happened to me.
Again, it wasn't like I
became a completely
different person overnight.
But there are a lot of
personality and emotional
changes that happen to brain
injury patients.
And so it led me on this
question of, do our brains
define who we are?
"I've been asked, do you
think your brain
defines who you are?
Interesting question.
I've learned that our brain
function is responsible for
not just our physical being but
how we plan, whether we're
organized or not, how much
initiative we have, and
whether we get angry, sad,
happy, or hopeful.
It conducts each instrument
that makes up the grand
orchestra of who we are.
He's a go-getter.
She's a neat-freak.
She's good with numbers.
He's such a spontaneous guy.
All of these personality types
and traits that define us as
human beings can be impacted
by damage to our brains.
If that happens, then
who are we?
Does brain function dictate your
personality or, if you
believe personality is a part
of your soul, then does that
come first?
And if it does come first, does
it dictate the way your
brain learns to operate?
I strongly believe that your
brain function impacts your
personality, but it doesn't have
to define who you are.
My cognitive deficits and
emotional changes threatened
to change my very core, leaving
paralyzing fear,
sadness, and frustration
in their wake.
But the ability to fight through
them, to keep trying
to find a way around them, to
deal with the tears by trying
to find something to laugh at,
that's all a very real part of
who I was before the injury.
These days, I realize that this
desire to keep moving
forward, to keep pushing through
is what makes me who I
am, pre or post brain injury.
As a result, the success or
failure of the attempt doesn't
really matter.
My hope is twofold.
First, that people take brain
injury more seriously and
understand what its effects
can be on those
they know and love.
And second, that it doesn't
take a brain aneurysm for
people to learn the lessons I
learned about slowing down,
finding the humor, having more
patience, and savoring each
activity in our 24 by
7 connected world.
Everyday challenges can present
a new opportunity to
reboot, start over, and re-frame
the conversation with
your work, your relationships,
and with yourself.
It's not easy.
And like me, you won't be great
at it every single day.
But again, it's the attempt that
matters the most, not the
outcome."
So I just want to leave you with
a quote that I've found
that kind of has given me
comfort through this journey.
And I'm going to paraphrase,
because I--
short-term memory.
I can't seem to remember
the exact quote.
And then we're going to take
some questions, if you guys
have questions about brain
injury or writing the book or
anything like that.
But there's a quote that I found
that said something to
the effect of, life's challenges
are not meant to
paralyze you.
They're supposed to show
you who you are.
And I really believe that.
I really believe that it's
when we're tested--
and I know that sounds trite--
but that's when the real
you comes out,
brain injury or not.
And the real hearts of those
around you come out as well.
So I was very fortunate to
have a really supportive
community of friends and family
that flew in from all
over the country
to be with me.
But I know that there's a lot
of brain injury patients who
are abandoned by
their families.
Their families don't understand
the personality
changes or the psychological
changes that are taking place.
And it's those people, many of
whom I met in my rehab group,
that are the reason that I wrote
this book, because more
people need to understand what
these effects of brain injury
are, again, even if a
person looks fine.
So thanks for your time.
And I will take any questions,
if you guys have any.
I'm pretty open, so you
can ask me anything.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MARIA ROSS: I'm sorry?
MARIA ROSS: I will, for sure.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
would you say you're a happier
person now, with all these
things you've learned, than you
were before your accident?
MARIA ROSS: So the question was,
do I think I'm a happier
person now than I was before
because of all the things that
I've learned?
I have to admit, I was
pretty happy before.
But I think I'm just
more aware.
And so it's made my life a
little bit more richer.
I think I was always just going,
going, going on the
treadmill and not really
realizing why
I was going, before.
I was just always looking for
the next job opportunity, the
next career advancement, the
next activity I could
participate in.
And I wasn't really stopping
long enough to consider why.
And so now, because I have to
be more thoughtful about my
day and my schedule and the
things that I choose to
volunteer for or get dragged
into or whatever you want to
call it, I feel like
I'm living with a
little bit more intention.
Again, not every day, but I'm
not some Yogi on the mat.
So I guess, in that respect, I'm
a little bit more present
in my life now than I was
before, which, before, I
probably would have said was
a bunch of psychobabble.
But I kind of get it now.
So thanks.
Any other questions you guys
have about brain injury or
anything like that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MARIA ROSS: So the question is,
how have things have been
like using this platform
of education and
inspiration of the book?
Is that kind of a
good summary?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MARIA ROSS: It's actually
been really great.
I still have my consultancy
and my branding business.
But I feel like this has
opened up a whole
other avenue for me.
I'm actually going to be
speaking on a lot more medical
conferences, representing the
patient point of view, not
just about brain injury
but just about
patient care in general.
And I took this as an
opportunity to go volunteer at
the hospital that
saved my life.
When I was still in Seattle, I
became a patient adviser on
the family and education
committee.
And basically, I was the
voice of reality.
When they were trying to think
of new programs and new
training modules, I was like,
yeah, that's too complicated.
Or yeah, they're not going
to be looking at that.
So I've used that as an
opportunity to be able to
educate about brain injury.
But I just think like, everybody
else, I just wasn't
really as aware.
And I grew up in a house where,
in high school, my
great aunt had suffered
a stroke.
And she was living with us.
My mother was taking
care of her.
And I had no idea what was
going on with her.
I had no idea, at 14, why she
had become a different person.
And I don't know if she actually
was aware, as aware
as I am, of what was
happening to her.
But you just hear the same
stories over and over.
And like I said, I keep
getting these emails.
And it doesn't really matter
what the injury is.
People are like, oh my god,
I read your book.
And I didn't have a brain
aneurysm, but everything you
described was like my story.
And so just really understanding
these effects,
because I alluded to
the fact about
people in my group rehab.
I remember one guy in
particular, which was so sad.
His wife was divorcing him
because she couldn't
understand why he was lazy now
and couldn't get his act
together and was having such a
hard time just getting back
into his life and getting back
to work after, I think, it was
a car accident.
And I remember when he finally
was educated about, these are
the common effects
of brain injury.
And he went down the list
and went, yep, yep, yep.
He's like, I'm going to take
this binder home and show it
to my wife, because she thinks
I'm making all this up.
Which is just really sad to me,
because I imagine it's got
to be very hard to
live with that.
I know it's been challenging
for my husband, at times.
But at least he was willing to
understand and educate himself.
And I was very fortunate
about that.
But when we talk about the
concussions, like that
happened Alex Smith and
whatever, I'm so glad those
guys are getting pulled
out of the game.
Because right around the time
that I had my brain aneurysm,
there was a high schooler in
Seattle, named Zack Lystedt.
I don't know if any of you
guys have heard of him.
But he got a concussion during
a game and was put back in--
or during practice.
I can't remember.
And he collapsed on the field
and was taken to, actually,
the same place that
I was taken to,
the same trauma center.
He's just learning
to walk again.
And this was four years ago.
So, again, the diagnosis is
not, how many fingers am I
holding up, and do you
know your name?
Because I was able to answer
those questions.
But I don't even remember
answering those questions.
So I'm really happy to see
that that awareness is
building up, with people taking
brain injury more
seriously, that sometimes the
effects can't be seen.
But we need to be just really
careful when we fall or get in
a car accident or take a
hit by the end zone.
We really need to be more
cognizant of that.
Sorry, I got on my
soapbox there.
Any other questions?
Do any of you guys have brain
injury or stroke in your
family or know anyone that
is brain injured?
Is it a stroke or?
AUDIENCE: It was an accident.
MARIA ROSS: An accident.
So those are called traumatic
brain injuries, versus what I
had is called an acquired
brain injury, because it
happened organically.
But that's the thing with
concussion, is that TBIs can
cause aneurysms to form.
And so, going back to the
football thing, that's why, if
they do have a concussion,
it can cause a
future brain aneurysm.
I don't know if any of this
resonates for you, with this
person's behavior, but maybe.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, my mother-in-law
actually had an
aneurysm that ruptured,
like, I think it
was seven years ago.
MARIA ROSS: Did she survive?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MARIA ROSS: Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: But it was similar,
a lot of the
things you talked about.
[INAUDIBLE].
She collapsed in the
bathroom, too.
MARIA ROSS: Everybody's
in the bathroom.
I don't know why.
It's weird.
At least they're not
on the road.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] grandma,
[INAUDIBLE].
She was showering, and
then [INAUDIBLE].
She was in the shower for,
like, 40 minutes.
She went up and checked
on her, and she was--
MARIA ROSS: Oh my gosh.
AUDIENCE: --unconcious.
She called the [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know.
It makes me have a lot of
respect for her recovery,
because she is doing
amazingly, too.
And she's [INAUDIBLE].
MARIA ROSS: Yeah, and the
interesting thing, which is I
never really had a stance about
health care reform.
But we were very fortunate.
My husband was working for
Microsoft, and they covered
everything, 100%.
And our medical bills
were well over
half a million dollars.
And I've talked to aneurysm
groups who didn't even know
about some of the rehab
groups after.
Because, since they didn't have
insurance, they weren't
going to be able to get into
those rehab groups.
And yes, the doctor saving your
actual life is important.
But what gets you back into
society again, as a productive
member of society, is
the follow-up rehab.
And that's where the care falls
down, because a lot of
insurance companies don't cover
the rehab, because they
think it's a luxury, versus hey,
at least let the person
take the full eight weeks.
And then they can be back
to work and back being
productive.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because she just
retired, but she would
like to [INAUDIBLE].
MARIA ROSS: That's good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: She definitely
[INAUDIBLE].
I mean, my mom does too.
MARIA ROSS: Well, I can't
explain it anymore.
It's not that I can't do things
I didn't do before,
necessarily.
I used to be really, really
good at project planning.
I was queen of that.
I organized an 80-city global
roadshow in one of my
technology jobs before.
The thought of actually seeing a
blank spreadsheet right now,
and organizing a project like
that, with multiple tabs, just
makes my head spin.
I wouldn't even know.
I get really overwhelmed.
That's a big effect
that hits a lot of
brain injury patients.
As I was mentioning, that
filter gets damaged.
And so in the book, I have an
example of, it's like the
bouncer of my brain was
really good before.
And now he got replaced with
someone who's brand new.
And he just lets everything
in at the same time.
So for example, in this group,
we're completely focused.
And I can talk to you guys.
If there was another meeting
going on over there, it's hard
for me to filter out
what's going on.
So things like that just
require more effort.
So I'd have to spend more effort
trying to focus on this
conversation.
It hits me in restaurants
all the time.
And stroke victims and aneurysm
patients always talk
about this, that they have
a really hard time with
filtering out conversations in
a restaurant, because your
brain's taking everything in the
equal weight, because your
filter is broken.
And it leaves you exhausted,
because if you can imagine
taking everything in at the
same time, you're chugging
really hard to try to stay
focused on the person that
you're talking to.
And that can exhaust
you after an hour.
So no texting and
talking for me.
I try not to.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
breaking a leg, where it's
obvious [INAUDIBLE].
MARIA ROSS: That's really
good question, actually.
So the question was, since
there's a lot of unseen
effects, did I come up with
strategies to tell people that
I might be struggling?
Is that where you're
going with that?
So it's just funny that you
chose to use the word
"strategies," because that's
the big word in rehab is
coming up with strategies to
deal with your issues.
And they use that word
all the time.
But yeah, I mean, it was kind
of challenging for me at
first, because I didn't know how
much of it to bring into
my business.
I don't want to be a brand
consultant to $30 million
companies and say like, oh,
I forget stuff sometimes.
So I have found ways to
work around that.
This sounds silly, but
I write down a lot
more than I used to.
So I'm always taking notes,
or I'm always recording.
And even today, I
have my notes.
So I'm always writing stuff
down, whereas before,
I didn't have to.
So that's not necessarily
something that
people would notice.
But sometimes I will ask the
same question twice in one
conversation, because I've
forgotten what the answer was.
So it hasn't caused too
much of an issue.
And most of the partners that
I work with on projects know
about my situation.
So I tend to rely on them.
If we're having a conference
call, I'll make sure I'm
taking notes, and somebody else
is taking notes so that,
if I missed something or I
didn't understand something,
they have my back.
But it hasn't been a situation
where people have
been mean about it.
But I don't necessarily
go like,
hi, I want your business.
And I had a brain injury.
I don't lead with that.
But if they go to my website,
they'll know that I'm an
author and that I've
written this book.
And ironically, bringing that
into my brand, as a business,
has actually really helped
my business because it
differentiates me,
in a weird way.
But they also just see this
story of overcoming adversity,
and they feel like, well, that's
kind of a person that I
want to work with, which
I was surprised.
I wasn't sure how people we're
going to respond to that.
I joke with my husband.
I call it, playing the brain
injury card, about if
something goes wrong.
I've never not delivered
something for a client and
blamed it on my brain injury
or anything like that.
But there have been a couple
things that, literally, is
because of my overwhelm
problem or whatever.
And I've just found a
way to deal with it.
I double check everything.
I turn off my email, while I'm
trying to work on something
with people.
So those are the kinds
of strategies that
I've tried to employ.
But yeah, there's only been one
or two times where I've
told somebody, you have to slow
down, because I have to
write this down, because
I had a brain injury.
Because then that invites
a whole bunch of other
questions, right?
It's like, oh, what's that?
And when did that happen?
You're like, no, I'm just trying
to get the information
down right now.
So good question, though.
Thanks.
Anyone else?
No?
Well, thanks for your
time today.
I really appreciate it.
And I hope you enjoy the book.